[Music]
on this tuesday night from weldon
saskatchewan a wanted man's history of
violence miles sanderson's troubling
track record i trust that he will be
caught what his parole board record
reveals and why he was freed months ago
shock and heartache it's not the same
without what the grief and trauma
gripping these small communities and
trying to solve canada's healthcare
crisis you just can't keep doing the
same thing and expecting a different
result a possible controversial
prescription
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight from weldon
saskatchewan
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are in weldon saskatchewan a village
in a province on edge tonight the rcmp
is still trying to find miles sanderson
he's the fugitive wanted in that deadly
stabbing spree that unfolded here in
this community and the james smith cree
nation 11 people were killed that
includes the wanted man's brother 18
others are injured for several hours
today the focus of that manhunt shifted
back to the james smith cree nation
after reports of a possible sighting
there we have complete coverage tonight
mike armstrong is in regina outside rcmp
headquarters heather yorick's west is
here in
walden she just got back from the james
smith cree nation heather what happened
with that alert yeah donna that alert
came out early this afternoon warning
the public that miles anderson had been
spotted on the james smith cree nation
now we were driving near the crenation
around that time and noticed a heavy
police presence traveling towards the
area about 15 police vehicles with their
sirens on there was a helicopter
overhead one of the vehicles was it was
a heavily armored vehicle very tense
moments
the
reserve
reserve rather was put under lockdown
for about two and a half hours
but in the end there was no suspect
taken into custody police were able to
determine that this was a false alarm
and the manhunt tonight continues donna
all right we'll come back to you in a
little bit heather for the latest on the
victims those who were killed at their
families and of course those who were
injured but we want to go to mike
armstrong now who's in regina outside
our cmp headquarters mike you just spoke
to the saskatchewan rcmp commanding
officer what did she tell you
yeah we spoke to assistant commissioner
rhonda blackmore she's the commanding
officer here for saskatchewan rcmp
blackmore said this morning they had
multiple reports that sanderson was
spotted on the james smith crenation
officers were dispatched and that the
alert was issued after searching the
area the report was deemed to be
unfounded and that alert was lifted
which brings us back to the most recent
sighting which would be sunday in the
eastern part of this city regina police
say it was credible that sighting
sanderson in a black nissan rogue
apparently with another person the head
of the saskatchewan rcmp still says they
have reason to trust that sighting but
it's now being more than 48 hours
sanderson could have moved and she's
basically saying that anybody in this
part of the country should be vigilant
until we have a resolution to this
incident by having miles sanderson in
custody there's still a threat he has
shown a
significant propensity for violence he
has committed incredibly traumatic and
violent crimes
in james smith at crenation and weldon
and
we want to make sure that the public
remains vigilant because we cannot say
what his thought process is right now or
what his behavior might be right now we
want to make sure that everyone remains
vigilant until this individual is caught
and i take it that's why you took no
chances with the alert this morning that
is exactly why we did that
now the police investigation into those
crimes continues but they're also being
questions
raised on another front global news has
obtained court documents outlining miles
sanderson's very troubled criminal past
and there are now questions being raised
as to whether the parole board may have
made a mistake
releasing sanderson from his latest
sentence
early
at the time of this attack miles
sanderson was already on the run from
police he'd been released from prison
but had stopped meeting with his
caseworker since may 27th he was
officially designated as unlawfully at
large now his criminal history is
extensive and violent sanderson has 59
criminal convictions since turning 18
and he's only 31 years old according to
court documents there are multiple
recent incidents in one sanderson
threatened an ex-girlfriend to the point
children had to be hidden in a bathtub
in another he beat a man and forced him
to commit an armed robbery and in
another he attacked two brothers
stabbing them with a fork and beat
another man unconscious who had just
been walking by
when sanderson was arrested in june of
2018 he assaulted an officer and told
police they were going to have to shoot
him he was sentenced to four years and
four months but was released in august
2021 on statutory release it didn't go
well sanderson was caught lying to his
caseworker and in november his release
was suspended well he fought to have it
reinstated and earlier this year won
that's why he was out the parole board
issued a decision on sanderson february
1st of this year it lays out a serious
history of drug and alcohol abuse that
started at just 12 years old it says his
criminal history is quote very
concerning including the use of violence
and weapons and his history of domestic
violence however the parole board found
he would not present an undue risk and
that freeing him would contribute to the
protection of society by facilitating
his reintegration
now there were several conditions to
sanderson's release no alcohol no drugs
he was to follow a treatment plan he
couldn't have any contact with several
specific people or anyone he knew that
was involved in criminal activity but
the board said it was quote satisfied
that your risk is manageable in the
community donna all right mike armstrong
in regina tonight thanks well while this
manhunt continues to unfold friends and
family of those killed on sunday or
grieving a lot of people on the james
smith cree nation are not speaking to
the media the leadership of the nation
has told them to avoid the media
others though are making a point of
seeking out the media and and telling
them
a story about
they what they say they hope will
highlight the deep rooted problems that
may have contributed to this mass
killing heather urex west has been
speaking to some of them heather yeah
the family of one of the victims say
that the james smith cree nation needs
help they say that the problems of drugs
and alcohol addictions fueled by trauma
are now fueling violence and across
canada the james smith crenation is not
alone in this
down this road on the james smith cree
nation the community is privately
dealing with a collective trauma my
sister was lying
in a driveway
with her friend
and a young boy to all that
ivor and daryl burns lost their sister
gloria in sunday's attack when it's
believed two community members brothers
damien and miles sanderson began a
series of assaults so vicious 10 people
were killed and another 18 injured my
sister
worked at the health clinic she was a
front line worker
she was she got called out
she got called out on a crisis
call
and that's when she met her demise the
battle we're fighting here is with with
alcoholism and drug drug use
and
when we're talking of
and even that is just a symptom of the
out of the residential school
syndrome damien and miles sanderson were
well known to the burns family they are
in fact related but daryl burns says the
brothers were caught up in a cycle of
intergenerational trauma that led them
to frequent drug and alcohol abuse you
see a lot of our people angry
you know anger is a secondary emotion
the primary emotion is is hurt and pain
and
so yeah there's a lot of hurt and pain
in our communities on alberta's sixth
sycamation buckbreaker says the problems
are all too familiar trauma passed down
from grandparents to parents to children
fueling a cycle of drug and alcohol
addiction and domestic violence we need
programs and services for people our
people the moment they say they want
help we've got to have something there
for them for men
we don't have enough
programs and services for men males need
to heal
still there is some hope remaining here
after losing his mother gloria dylan
burns thought too about turning to drugs
and alcohol to cope
but instead he says he did what his mom
would have wanted he danced
this is a healing grass dance he
performed at the wabitin dakota nation
pow-wow near prince albert
this time to deliberately break the
cycle of trauma and violence for his
family and his people back home
and we have an update to the injured the
people injured in this attack the 17
that were admitted to hospital the
saskatchewan health authority say that
uh four seven have now been discharged
four remain in critical condition and we
also will be hearing from the james
smith cree nation on thursday donald all
right heather urix west thanks for this
to other news there is more controversy
surrounding the public inquiry into the
nova scotia massacre today the mass
casualty commission heard testimony from
constable greg wiley he's an rcmp
officer who visited the gunman
frequently over several years while he
denied investigating a 2010 complaint
the gunman threatened to kill his own
parents he also says he does not recall
a 2011 bulletin warning police the
gunman expressed desire to kill a police
officer commission order did prevent the
media from showing the testimony today
for what it called personal health
considerations a lawyer for victims
families says that just further
undermines public confidence in the
inquiry
a new chapter in british politics coming
up the latest prime minister's first day
on the job and the pledges she's making
welcome back to saskatchewan the interim
leader of the federal conservative party
candice burgin has announced she will
not run in the next federal election
bergen made the announcement in a
facebook post she served as the party's
interim leader since february when aaron
o'toole was ousted by his caucus bergen
was first elected to the house of
commons in 2008 she says she'll serve
out her term as the mp for the manitoba
riding of portage lisgar the
conservatives will choose their next
leader at a convention on saturday
and the uk has a new prime minister liz
truss is now in charge and after meeting
with the queen she wasted little time
appointing cabinet ministers she wants
to work with the outgoing prime minister
boris johnson shared his plans for his
future as he stepped away from downing
street
i am now like one of those booster
rockets
that has fulfilled its function
and i will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
pacific
never lost for words as crystal
commansing reports as johnson departs
his successor is inheriting a big
portfolio of problems
it's out with the old and in with the
new
a lashing rain however forced prime
minister liz trust motorcade to keep
driving hoping for a break in the
weather allowing for more suitable
arrival at 10 downing street
the forecast foreshadowing the
challenges she faces
i am confident that together we can ride
out the storm her first speech to the
nation included a pledge to cut taxes
fund the national health service and
take action this week to address
skyrocketing energy bills
but people aren't convinced a u-gov poll
finds two-thirds of britons have little
to no confidence and trust to tackle the
cost of living
we'll get spades in the ground to make
sure people are not facing unaffordable
energy bills and we will also make sure
that we are building hospitals schools
roads of broadband trust is the third
woman to be invited by the queen to form
government and her majesty's 15th prime
minister her 14th boris johnson pushed
out in part after being found to have
repeatedly lied about hosting and
attending parties during the pandemic
johnson always a performer hearkened
back to roman times in his farewell
like cincinnatus
i am returning to my plow
and i will be offering this government
nothing but the most fervent support
the plow in this case likely the back
benches he'll be joined by another
former leader there theresa may they
will both be in parliament wednesday
when trust stands for her first prime
minister's questions crystal gamansen
global news
london
canada's healthcare crisis continues
ahead do private companies hold a key to
relief
welcome back to saskatchewan the mass
stabbing here on sunday further tested
this province's already stressed health
care system a code orange mass casualty
event was declared at saskatoon's royal
university hospital three patients ended
up being flown there by air ambulance
for emergency care
last week the head of saskatchewan's
nurses union warned the hospital was
experiencing what she called a dire
staffing crisis she gave the example of
august 24th when the emergency room was
operating 200 percent over capacity more
than 90 people waiting to access 31
available beds
what's happening at royal university
mirrors the staffing crisis in other
hospitals across canada many ers have
been temporarily closed and the state of
canadian health care has reignited the
long-running debate about privatization
jamie morocco has more on what a system
with more options could mean for
patients
vancouver surgeon dr brian day
isn't shy about sharing his opinion on
canadian health care
canada's health system is performing
badly the clinic owner has spent decades
crusading for a parallel private system
to ease stress on our public hospitals
and save lives he says the promise
was that we would have a universal
system where everyone was treated but
people are dying on weightless just last
month the bc court justice agreed the
two-tier ban in that province imposes
suffering on patients stuck in the
public cue but as it stands medical
services offered under the canada health
act cannot also be covered by private
insurance and the mere mention of
privatization creates conflict and
political polarization we just can't as
a province keep doing the same thing
and expecting a different result the
national health care crisis has some
leaders in ontario alberta saskatchewan
and quebec exploring relationships with
private companies but it's unclear in
exactly what capacity and at who's cost
in germany citizens who have the money
can opt out of the country system for
substitute of coverage a popular choice
in australia is to pay for insurance to
access private facilities and even the
uk which has a revered universal health
care system offers private options still
these countries aren't immune to post
pandemic backlogs or wait times
privatization of anything would make no
difference in the emergency room public
health physician dr michael ratchlis
wants to see canada focus on optimizing
existing facilities like this one of the
largest surgical centers in north
america that sits just outside downtown
toronto we've got the solutions of the
public sector but when people don't hear
about them if you don't know what's on
the menu you can't ask for it managing
patient levels should start outside the
er explains this harvard health expert
the nature of those peaks and valleys
are elective scheduled admissions so if
you smooth those peaks and valleys you
can dramatically improve your operation
with the immediate goal of alleviating
burnout increasing retention and
improving patient care jamie morocco
global news toronto
a new report by the alzheimer's society
of canada found over one million
canadians could be diagnosed with
dementia by 2030. that almost doubles
the number of cases in canada right now
and the number could triple by 2050. in
many cases we know family members are
caring for their loved ones the study
says in the next 30 years those roles
will equal about 700 000 full-time jobs
the best way
to advance is to prevent as many cases
as possible that requires reducing risk
factors such as substance abuse
traumatic injuries and pollution the
study authors admit this requires
individual as well as community and
government support to succeed
rain and cooler temperatures bringing
some relief to crews fighting the
wildfire burning in jasper national park
the fire now mapped at an area of about
6 000 hectares is down from about 8 000
hectares yesterday it's burning about 16
kilometers north of the resort town of
jasper at this point there are no
evacuation orders or alerts in place
but visitors are being asked to
reconsider their plans the flames have
damaged power lines into town there's no
word on when electricity will be fully
restored
a community's grief next we speak to the
people of weldon in the aftermath of the
senseless violence here
welcome back to weldon saskatchewan a
community on edge weldon is just a
pretty tiny prairie village less than
200 people live here everyone knows the
man who was murdered here outside his
home and though there's still plenty of
prairie friendliness here people are
understandably nervous
the idea this tiny village would ever be
in the media spotlight is as foreign to
people here as locking their front doors
the murder of a neighbor in what's
believed to be a random attack has
changed everything i wonder if he
actually ever left the area
tamara shabaga goes to church here and
is doing some painting today
it could have been anybody in town like
everyone here she knew wes peterson i
was supposed to work yesterday here and
i didn't come
obviously because
i was a little nervous about it
um
but i thought you know what life goes on
we have to
not live in fear and
trust the lord that he'll look after us
that it happened here feels unreal
peterson's niece who didn't want to go
on camera said she's still trying to
wrap her head around his murder and the
fact that one of the suspects is still
out there i killed an innocent man for
nothing ruby works says she's nervous
too but wants the world to know her
friend was a good man we're not seeing
anybody out and about in the town
today no
get that terrified
because there's a fear that the other
brother might come back the other
brother might come back and pick another
random house and do it again
we all fear this
and for good reason while tamara shabago
was painting the church another
emergency alert
a suspected sighting of the wanted man
on the james smith first nation that's
just a half hour drive from weldon
that prompted tamara to think twice
about leaving the church open she's
locked the doors and what will make the
community feel more at ease what will
make you feel more at ease
they catch the brother
and put him behind bars
and late today the rcmp said that
suspected sighting on the james smith
cree nation was a false alarm the
suspect has not been found the manhunt
still underway
that is global national for this tuesday
from saskatchewan a province that
remains on high alert thanks for
watching
[Music]
you